big Tech must not censor the voices of
the American people censor what you say
and think Twitter which will just
randomly silence somebody a week after
they tweet something amid the debate
over free speech on the internet
alternative social media apps have
surged in popularity truth social the
twitter-like platform launched by former
president Donald Trump was the most
downloaded free iPhone app earlier this
year now Kanye West who goes by yay may
be in the mix with a deal to buy the
social media Network parlor this comes
after Twitter banned him and amid Adidas
and GAP parting ways with the rapper
following weeks of erratic behavior and
anti-semitic comments so what could
West's involvement mean for the site and
how does it fit into this growing
Universe of alternative social media
launched in 2018 parlor attracted
millions of users by pitching itself as
a Free Speech Twitter alternative
prominent conservative donor Rebecca
Mercer is among the company's Financial
backers according to parlor's former CEO
John matz this platform and others like
it tend to attract people who want to
speak their minds very freely and may
host content that's considered offensive
language that wouldn't be allowed on on
more mainstream platforms several of its
users have been banned by other large
social networks
this includes Alex Jones a far-right
talk show host and conspiracy theorist
as well as supporters of The Proud boys
the group that helped lead the January 6
attack on the U.S Capitol in early 2021
Apple Amazon and Google kicked parlor
off their app stores after the site
hosted calls for violence around the
time of the January 6 riot at the
Capitol essentially parlor was knocked
off the internet so it was not operating
as an app and it wasn't operating as a
website either Apple and Google later
restored the site to their app stores
but parlor has struggled to maintain a
large user base since
in October the site's parent company
Parliament Technologies said it agreed
to a deal in principle with West to buy
the platform for undisclosed terms this
happened shortly after Mr West was
locked out of Twitter and Instagram for
posting anti-semitic content in owning
his own social media platform he would
have the freedom to post the kind of
content that might not be allowed on
other platforms West could not
immediately be reached for comment but
in a press statement disclosed by
Parliament Technologies he said in a
world where conservative opinions are
considered to be controversial we have
to make sure we have the right to freely
express ourselves parlor is just one of
the social media networks that have
emerged with Promises of looser
moderation policies sites like bit shoot
and gab also built themselves as Havens
for free speech and alternatives to
mainstream media they came to be as a
way to give users the opportunity to
speak more freely on the other hand that
sometimes means allowing people to post
content that large groups of people
might find offensive that might be
considered anti-semitic or just racist
some of these alternative social media
sites have also become hotbeds for
conspiracy theories and misinformation
according to audits of the websites from
the Pew Research Center social media
apps like gab Han parlor have come under
Fire for allowing their users to post
content that's been considered offensive
or harmful dangerous inciting violence
the founder of 8-chan could not be
reached for comment a spokesperson for
parlor said conspiracy theory and
misinformation are terms used to
undercut those platforms daring to
remind people that they have the right
to speak freely in a statement [ __ ]
should said Can Freedom be real when
your silence is required and added that
it supports West
gab another alternative to Facebook and
Twitter was linked to a 2018 mass
shooting at a Pittsburgh synagogue the
shooter had a history of posting
anti-semitic speech on the platform gab
CEO said the platform cooperates with
law enforcement to ensure that anyone
who would abuse our site harm anyone or
make terroristic threats is brought to
Justice the law says that social media
companies aren't responsible for the
content it's users post some of these
platforms are also increasingly backed
by prominent conservatives former
president Donald Trump launched his own
social network called Truth social after
Twitter borrowed him from the platform
following the January 6 attack at the
Capitol Google recently approved truth
social for distribution in its mobile
app store opening a new potential
customer base for the startup app in
2021 the alternative video platform
Rumble said it was expecting an
investment from a group of prominent
conservative Venture capitalists this
included Peter Thiel and hillbilly elegy
author JD Vance and Elon Musk the
world's wealthiest person recently
completed his takeover of Twitter with
plans to loosen its moderation controls
at a Ted conference in April he said
well I think it's very important for
uh there to be an inclusive arena for
free speech looking ahead for West The
Parlor deal is expected to close later
this year in a press statement parlor's
CEOs said the acquisition would change
the way the world thinks about Free
Speech despite high profile backers data
suggests that the alternative social
platforms have struggled to gain
traction with a wide audience in
September parlor said it had more than
16 million registered users by
comparison Twitter has more than 230
million users on the platform each day
meanwhile a recent study by the Pew
Research Center found that fewer than 1
in 10 Americans read alternative social
media sites for news the study also
found that 15 percent of prominent
accounts on alternative social media
sites have been banned or demonetized
elsewhere on the internet While most
alternative social media apps don't have
as many users as more established
companies collectively they have begun
to shape a new environment for some
conservative voices